hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is yamimash hello everyone I'm
yamimash and we are here to play another
gmod horror map we've gone through some
crappy ones but we're gonna forget about
that one because you guys recommended
death of the dream too even though death
of the dream wasn't wasn't too fantastic
you guys suggested this would be a good
one so have a very good feeling that
this is gonna be scary as hell okay
Morgan Freeman alright
so carrying on it is watching us ten
eyes 20 insane traps everywhere need
help sacrifice you know them away hello
you save the hair do not touch the
engines ah oh hello
there's a guy down here at Matt Matt how
what well you're the guy huh
this guy seems to be dead I think he's
been impaled multiple time jumps down in
check okay hey you dead is he dud he's
got the creepiest look on his face he
looks dead
alright is dead he failed do not blame
me you failure die why do these people
want us to die so bad they just hate us
no I've got a bad feeling about this one
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] aroun II who do i your
Jimbo oh oh hello oh this thing's
twitching yeah Oh dead so hungry I had
to eat her still hungry
disgust me I'm unhappy happy I am happy
died what there's something wrong with
this I don't know this might be a clue
to a puzzle I've got it confused what I
just think oh wow
what the hell attached it's it's a
shadow it's a shadow there was a shadow
in the last death of the room - hey um
Yami come here oh no said no Chang
no you sit in the chair I gotta get it
on camera oh my the things I do for you
ma ago just do this one more ow ha ha ha
ow ow okay okay you're in the chair okay
yeah yeah feel anybody no nothing's
happening
No
right no I guess you're blinded okay
don't close the door on me okay do not
bother him
my father : hey MA Oh get out get out
get out get out get out get out to it
get out of him I'm late - it was a hell
out on Jesus get out of here
oh I sign that chair for you okay oh no
the top Jesus Jesus oh it's amazing
Oh God thank you Oh probably the
freakiest thing I've ever seen in one of
these jihad [ __ ] maps so maybe maybe
there is it maybe they always got ha ha
maybe these suggestions were right okay
finally a good match yeah about time -
okay now just watches my recording fails
Hey
all right way Mikey Walker fires you
said no I went I talked to the guy you
you sacrifice yourself go in there [ __ ]
I ain't okay boy does this always happen
to me all right
it's for a good cause oh look at my ha
ha ha ha ha
these ronsis came out of the wall okay
what my way back what was the point of
that I don't know sacrifice for what I
did nothing happen oh you need to die
again sorry I didn't turn on the engine
what I killed you
Oh fine go I have to die yeah sorry yeah
I'm sorry the door and it leads to a
very very scary looking hallway but I'll
save that the use of your recording no
wait hang on where are you I'm I'm not
dumb kind of lost actually no no no
where'd you go notice I see you I see
you cut wait which way did you oh that
way
I mean what's down here have fun on it
oh hello there's a puzzle on the wall
all right so alpha beta C Delta
Omega epsilon these are obviously Greek
so I think it's two four two four one
three nine seven two four one three nine
seven so got two for one I missed every
nine seven [ __ ] no oh wait no there's
more over here up bollocks what the hell
and then you have two back ones I think
oh wait no there are all different
alphabets okay so okay so at a that's a
that's B so zero four zero four one five
nine zero four one five nine zero four
one five nine what the [ __ ]
gosh shut up [ __ ] follow me my bonus
show you some okay alright fine
you [ __ ] good yes I'm following up
following I dare you to go down there
well why just just go down there what's
down here anything happening no no no
think nothing boxes yeah boxes
it might do it I do what I'm doing it
don't do it I did it ha what the hell ha
ha ha ha look out ha ha ha
that's awesome no it's not this is not
awesome that is awesome you got admit
that's pretty awesome
ha ha ha you wanna die
is it gonna go faster is that it's only
speed I don't think it can go any faster
and now it's gone ha ha ha I wasn't so
bad Jose is playing cool yeah that's all
that's down here that's nothing else oh
that was it alright you got balls of
slider first two drinks laga lager death
awaits death away ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha you got cut off by a door that just
appeared oh my god I'm gonna die no
you know no oh no baby Sammy Sammy baby
Yami oh wow Tom the baby save the baby
ah the baby no no the baby ah ah ah
become a back okay so maybe just by
speaking to me I think I might have I
think I heard that through your mic
walls have eyes trust 900 come in come
in here can't read this it hungers ruin
if you sit you're ready no I'm not ready
to you ready
no I don't want to go to ready come on
come on I'm not doing it I'm not doing
come on cub our card Jana
come on yo [ __ ] bye auntie okay hi I
turned on a generator ready yeah hang on
I want you there are oh I get it there
are a certain number of generators in
the building okay come back okay see
come back to the beginning where we
spawned if you look yeah we've turned on
two generators look two lights are on
well sim you're right yeah okay so we
just need to find the last generator
which is bright through this door oh
okay yeah so since it says the alphabets
are reversed probably gotta go through
the Greek the Greek alphabet hmm so it's
not alphanumeric definitely hmm yeah we
got to use our brains um we gotta use
our brains Hey look at Wow very nice Oh
okay let's solve this puzzle Don ah crap
let's press this bud oh no I gotta press
these buttons here oh no they're shapes
ooh
supposed to put the shapes on the
platform no oh this was a written on the
wall this was totally written on the
wall I knew it was pirate puzzle with
two circles in a square in a triangle
that went in a loop-de-loop yeah yeah
yeah so how do we do this um we got a
puddin not sure gotta put the ship ha ha
ha
why can I never do it but you do it
every time I don't know I think Oh No
there we go oh wow we did it yeah
wowie Zowie there we go baby you just
smashed right through that door
you're so strong Yami you're so strong
I've been working out yeah I bet yeah
every day oh sure let's cool it me hey
I've had plenty of things happen to me
okay I click something that's degenerate
all right here we go here we go no
that's not the generator Oh Gabby hello
hey we come back live here Oh Oh God ah
ah it burns
uh okay yeah okay nice very very nice
uh-huh okay so we go through here oh are
you okay that's what it was lady but
those others like for you right yeah
it's pretty vicious oh man yeah Oh what
was that thing a very ugly guy yeah no
kidding okay you need it like a dental
job or something yeah okay all right ha
I just hear you laughing at the backer
that's exactly how I responded I left
what what oh come on you didn't see the
trip wire there I'm sorry Mac yeah I got
didn't look properly all right let's get
back
oh god y'all hear things I put up with
huh good I like you just go first for
everything
Oh God people giving me friend requests
gotta be interrupting
our thingies yeah damnit okay so now
that you tripped that aha
here's the last generator awesome let me
go we did it
got it I am the door between you and
them what and this is a UH this battle
is back in the air that's on okay we got
to go back to the entrance yes yeah
that's this way not this way this way
where is the entrance uh you could die
or we could go this way Oh John Koeppen
we got this okay which way do we go we
just open this door right here what
about this door Mia there's more Oh
what's wait what's this oh this is just
another observation room okay just gonna
straight forward okay here we go
go come on come on oh [ __ ] and is near
uh through these walls I would guess uh
uh uh uh uh uh uh uh there's a lot to
this place it was okay as three more
switches we got to find these weird
plaque yeah it's one right here okay
grab that one I'm gonna check out my
knees barrels what was that okay that
was the the cod I found that's two okay
so nothing else in here it hidden around
check in here hmm wait what's behind
here
aha nice I know I love it when you go
first and then fun though haha here's
another card Jesus
nice nice so keep a lookout right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah nothing nothing huh
yeah sure okay where did where did we
put these in in here
yeah thanks Tucker just one more one
more we need to find and then I'm
guessing Ashby we mean we win the game
maybe maybe maybe
oh good do you want me to go first oh
great is lesson of life and death Oh
what do we got
this doesn't look like a torture room
it's a classroom of course it does it's
a coal what Oh Shay
into me oh oh here's the last card got
it huh easy
well that jumps careful isn't as bad as
the other ones it was just kind of
standing there okay we're good we're
good
gotta make it we're gonna win this yeah
we don't die yay okay so I don't know
this is happen um guess it opened a door
somewhere yeah hey wait what's this was
this here before no the end hi yeah I
was the son nice alright we made it to
the end yeah ma'am now I'm actually I'm
so happy we spent so long trying to find
a good map and we finally found this
because I was I had my doubts about
death of the dream because of the first
one that that one was really good haha
so there's a lot of fun and I'm glad you
got scared a lot and I could laugh at
you yeah that's all the matter oh good
for you okay so thank you everybody so
much watching if you've got good map
suggestions that you want us to play
both me and yamimash give us write in
the comments below let us know things
that like this one with good jump scares
good atmosphere cool traps and
interactivity not so much combat so
thank you again and as always we will
see you what are you doing with that
rocket launcher hahaha
in the next video bye bye